- I don't even know if you
remember, but we actually,
we didn't, I don't know
if we met officially,
but I know we were both at the event,
I don't know if it was
in Canada or something,
- Yeah.
- I don't know,
but I got to hear you sing
and you are a stunningly gorgeous singer.
- You're weird, no, that's so crazy.
- No, no, you're so good!
- You're so funny!
- That's not even in this script,
I just wanted to say that.
- You're my first concert
I ever went to in my life.
- Oh Really?
- Yeah.
- You were young, how old were you?
- I had to be, I had to be seven or eight
and it was me and my mom and my sisters
and I still have the
poster from your concert,
it was the breakaway days
- Oh my God.
- which I still listen to
when I'm on airplanes and I cry,
(Kelly laughs)
so it's great.
But yeah, you were just such
an inspiration to me, so
- Oh, that's so kind!
- that's so crazy, thank you.
- I just wanted to tell you, I was like,
I don't even know if you remember,
but we were like next door neighbors
because our bath, well, I
don't know if we split it up,
but I don't remember
what it was, but anyway.
- Did we split a
bathroom? That's not good.
- I don't know if we
did or not but I kept,
I feel like we might have,
because I was worried.
I was like, what if I have
to go to like the bathroom?
(audience laughs)
- Sometimes the acoustics,
and you can hear, like if
I was doing my warm-ups,
- Exactly! All singers warm up
- you were doing your warm-ups
- in the bathroom, so
I'm like, well I can't
- Wait, did I hear you doing
your warm-ups in the bathroom?
- You probably did and
I'm very sorry, but yeah.
- Why would you be sorry? That's so funny.
- I'm a total choir nerd, like yeah.
- That's amazing, I love that.
- If I don't warm up, it goes away, so.